A swarm of bloodthirsty entities waits outside
the protective boundary that surrounds the solar
system. They surge through the vacuum of space
looking for vulnerabilities in the force field
that protects us from their destructive
powers. The creatures ram themselves
against the barrier again and again, trying
to break through. Upon impact the forcefield
shimmers a golden color and displays a series of
thaumaturgical symbols, but it holds. Suddenly,
something flies through the protective shield
from inside the solar system; it leaves a hole.
Two creatures enter our solar system before the
shield closes. This may be the end for humanity.
The Sixth Overseer sits at a computer
terminal massaging the bridge of his nose.
He has just logged into the Foundation
database to gather information on an
anomaly whose intentions are still unknown. The O5
Council wants him to vote on an extreme measure,
but he requires more information first. There is
something coming, he can feel it, and he thinks
it has something to do with SCP-1548.
O5-6 straightens his back and sits up
in his chair. He logs back into the Foundation
database and brings up the entry for SCP-1548.
He knows that this SCP has been connected
to some odd occurrences recently,
but what are its true intentions? Is
SCP-1548 trying to help save the universe?
Or is it a malicious entity hell bent
on destroying it? O5-6 must find out.
He scrolls through the first few entries. SCP-1548
itself is a series of solar phenomena that occur
at the south pole of the sun. During
these events the sun's plasma morphs
into different thaumaturgical symbols. Each
symbol is tens of thousands of miles across.
The symbols themselves have not all
been classified by the Foundation yet,
but, there are three that have
been observed multiple times.
The first is unnamed symbol that, when
inscribed on a telescopic device by a person
with thaumaturgic abilities, can identify psionic
entities with malicious intents. The second symbol
is known as the Kalaphastian Isle, which when
displayed on a material, strengthens it immensely,
and gives it the ability to absorb kinetic
and electromagnetic energy. The final symbol
is the 12 Holy Owls of Serrinithium. When this
symbol is affixed to an object any entity that
is killed by it will immediately annihilate
and take everything in its radius with it.
O5-6 jots a note on the pad of paper sitting
on his desk. He has seen some of these symbols
before; they are connected to the Ortothan
mythology. The practitioners of this religion
are known as the The Church of the Second Hytoth
and are a mix of human and alien entities whose
main purpose is to aid the guardian deity of the
universe, "Rakmou-leusan," in combating any threat
that may try to wipe out this existence.
There must be a connection between The
Church of the Second Hytoth and SCP-1548, O5-6
thinks. He scrolls back through the SCP-1548
file to the entry logged on May 17, 1983, the
first time an event connected to SCP-1548 was
recorded. A probe picked up the manifestation of
thaumaturgic symbols on the south pole of the sun.
It was odd, but nothing other than the
manifestation of the symbols seemed to occur.
This event was recorded as Extranormal Event-9008
and logged in the SCP database. The event was all
but forgotten until December 23, 2016 when the
activity of SCP-1548 really began to pick up.
On that day SCP-1548 began manifesting protection
symbols in rapid succession. Over the next few
months a dense cloud of ionized gas formed around
the solar system. This ionized wall of radiation
surrounded the heliopause, the boundary where the
sun’s radiation gives way to the vacuum of space.
Over time this cloud became thicker, until
no light from outside of the solar system
could enter. Foundation censorship protocols
were quickly used to disseminate false data,
suggesting that the solar system was passing
through a dense cloud of cosmic dust,
and that was what was altering the night
sky and causing the stars to disappear
But as O5-6 continues to scan the files, he
knows what the true cause of this phenomenon is.
It must be SCP-1548. But why? Is the anomaly
trying to protect us from something outside of
our solar system? Or is it trying to trap
humanity within, with no means of escape?
O5-6 stands up and stretches.
“That’s enough for today,”
he says outloud to the empty room. He walks
towards the door and reaches for the handle.
All of a sudden sirens start going off and
red lights begin to flash. O5-6 spins around
and runs back to the computer terminal. An
emergency alert begins coming through. The
Falcon Light5 rocket that launched earlier in
the day to bring supplies to the International
Space Station has spontaneously lost 50% of its
mass mid flight. O5-6 frantically begins typing;
he brings up videos from surveillance satellites.
The Overseer watches in horror as pieces of debris
and bodies of the crew float through the
silence of space. The rocket looks like it
has been cut directly down the middle, and half
of the structure has vanished from existence.
What is happening? Suddenly another
alert comes in. All communication
has been lost with the International Space
Station. Without warning the space station
begins broadcasting a series of cognitohazards.
O5-6 quickly changes the channel to stop the
signal from transmitting through his computer.
Reports start coming in from around the world
that anyone who continued listening to the
cognitohazard signals began entering trances,
then their brain completely
evaporated from their skulls.
There is a surge of thaumaturgic
particles in orbit around the Earth.
O5-6 traces the particles back to their source.
They came from SCP-1548. The signal from the ISS
stops abruptly. The entire space station
changes course. It is on a trajectory to
re-enter the Earth’s atmosphere. The friction
and heat will rip the space station apart.
O5-6 can’t believe what is happening. It
seems as if SCP-1548 helped humanity in
a way by stopping the signals from the ISS.
But how can he be sure that SCP-1548 wasn’t
responsible for the cognitohazards in the
first place? He needs more information.
O5-6 searches for answers as more anomalies
connected to SCP-1548 start occurring around
the world. During a political demonstration
in Berlin, a thaumaturgic Way opens up
that leads to a pocket dimension. Soon after
the appearance of the portal Koru Archpriest
Farah Onteus, the leader of the Church of
the Second Hytoth, makes an announcement.
He claims that the Way leads to a shelter, which
will protect people from the coming doom of the
universe. The people in the area, along with
members of the Church of the Second Hytoth,
make their way into the portal. Two
undercover Foundation agents follow
the group. After everyone has entered, the Way
immediately closes, there is no further contact.
What does the Church of the Second
Hytoth know that we don’t? O5-6 wonders.
He continues monitoring the situation and looking
for answers. Suddenly a message comes through all
Foundation channels. It is coming from the sun.
It is not SCP-1548, instead, it is SCP-179,
the humanoid permanently in space near the sun.
179 sends out one clear word in its signal:
“defend.” Who is SCP-179 talking to?
O5-6 thinks. What needs to be defended?
Is it humanity? Our solar system? The universe?
Another alarm begins to go off. “What now?”
O5-6 screams. He brings up the alert; the screen
flashes to the moon. O5-6 focuses in on where
the alert is coming from. It is a Foundation base
called Area-32. What remains left of the base is
reporting that SCP-2821 suddenly expanded in size,
formed a wormhole that led to another region of
the universe, and then vanished through it taking
38 Foundation members and 10 anomalies with it.
Sirens continue to go off. Distress signals
are being picked up on every channel. It
seems as if the world is coming to an
end, and everything that is happening is
somehow connected to SCP-1548. A static filled
transmission begins coming in from SCP-3417.
The words are urgent: “all Ortothans hear, all
Ortothans must listen now. The Stars are lost…”
static breaks up the transmission for a few
moments before it resumes. “...Ago the First
Invasion occurred. The gods were unprepared,
never comprehending the fragility of the universe
after its creation. The worlds must fight—.” The
transmission cuts off. Everything goes silent.
A pulsating SCP icon appears on
the screen of O5-6’s computer.
It is the part of the puzzle he has been waiting
for. In 1999 the O5 Council unanimously voted to
launch a mission called Seraph-1 to explore
beyond the heliosphere, and the mission’s
true purpose was to explore the plausibility
of extraterrestrial SCP objects in space.
The message that O5-6 just received is from
Seraph-1; it is relaying information back to
Earth. The video shows the barrier of ionized
radiation that SCP-1548 had created glowing
orange at the border of the heliopause.
The radioactive wall seems to be made up
of complex geometric patterns around 6,000 miles
across. Seraph-1 accelerates towards the barrier;
it smashes through the protective shell.
The probe has entered interstellar space.
O5-6 knows that everything he is seeing is on
a delay, as the information being sent back by
Seraph-1 needs to travel vast distances, and it
takes significant time for the signals to reach
Earth. After passing through the ionized
barrier the connection to Seraph-1 is lost.
Over the next few days O5-6 tries to
link the anomalies happening in the
solar system to SCP-1548. The Foundation
still hasn’t concluded if 1548 is harmful
or trying to protect the solar system in some
way. Then a message comes in from Seraph-1;
it has briefly regained communication with the
Foundation. Most of the probe’s instruments
have been destroyed , but its rear facing camera
is still broadcasting. O5-6 pulls up the feed.
He stares at the screen in horror as the images
unfold before him. The camera captures swarms
of unknown entities surrounding the heliopause.
The bodies of the entities are asymmetrical with
countless appendages and unknown structures
jutting out from their cores. They seem
to range in size from 10 kilometers to 10,000
kilometers across. Although, some seem to be so
large that their size can only be hypothesized.
The swarms crash into the protective barrier that
SCP-1548 has created around the solar system. Each
time part of the swarm rams the barrier thousands
of thaumaturgic symbols and solar flares appear at
the point of impact. Two entities that are later
classified as 1548-Ω-1 and 1548-Ω-2 are captured
entering the solar system by Seraph-1’s camera.
Video from Seraph-1 shows that as the probe exited
through the protective barrier it created a hole
that remained open for a few moments. During
the time that the shield of ionized radiation
was vulnerable 1548-Ω-1 and 1548-Ω-2 entered
through it. They are now inside the solar system.
SCP-1548 launches countermeasures in the
form of glowing red sigils that create
shockwaves to slow down Ω-1 and Ω-2. Ω-1 is
shaped like an eel with five contorted arms
radiating from its body, and a mouth
made of impossible geometric shapes.
Ω-2 has a tetrahedral structure that
leaves a trail of black rocks in its wake.
As the two entities move towards the sun
SCP-1548 becomes more active. It closes the
hole in the barrier before any other creatures of
the swarm can enter, and then launches hundreds of
concentrated blasts of thaumic energy at Ω-2. The
flares vaporize the entity in seconds. The last
thing the video feed of Seraph-1 captures before
it cuts out is 1Ω-1 disappearing from view as it
creeps towards the center of the solar system. It
has escaped the protective measures of SCP-1548.
After the O5 Council reviews the footage
they decide to deploy the SCPS Curtana to
intercept Ω-1. The orbital vessel is fully
equipped with experimental anomalous weapons
and propulsion systems. The Council is sure
that the Curtana will be able to destroy Ω-1.
Data coming in from other satellites
indicate that Ω-1 has destroyed Pluto
and other Kuiper Belt objects. It is slowly
making its way to the center of the solar system,
annihilating everything in its path.
The Curtana intercepts Ω-1 near Jupiter
and engages the creature. After ten minutes
of battling, communication with the ship
is lost. Probes in the area capture footage
of the Curtana and Ω-1 in mid battle
when they are suddenly surrounded by a
black substance and both vanish from sight.
O5-6 and the other council members watch in
anticipation, unsure of what has just happened.
Then the black substance dissipates. The SCPS
Curtana sits motionless in space. The entity
is nowhere to be seen. A cheer erupts from the
Overseers and Foundation members in the room. It
seems the entity has been defeated. Then, without
warning, The Curtana accelerates rapidly. It is on
a collision course with Mars. As the ship hurtles
past one of the probes in the asteroid belt the
Foundation members see an organic mass resembling
that of Ω-1 attached to the hull of the ship.
The Overseer Council watches in horror as
the SCPS Curtana smashes into the red planet
leaving a crater 250 miles wide. The energy
released from the impact instantly ionizes
the thin atmosphere of Mars, causing
the surface to turn into molten rock.
From the epicenter of the impact crater a black
organic mass begins to crawl across the planet.
The Overseers are frozen in fear, but SCP-1548
immediately deals with the entity
that is devouring the surface of Mars.
From the sun comes the largest SCP-1548 instance
ever recorded. A solar flare is jettisoned towards
Mars. The impact causes a fusion reaction
so intense, that for a moment, Mars shines
as brightly as the sun. The planet explodes.
Its debris is cast across the solar system.
Over time it will create a second asteroid
belt in the orbit that Mars once inhabited.
The Overseer Council is now convinced
that the threat has been dealt with.
SCP-1548 is holding the swarm at
bay outside of the solar system,
at least for the moment. O5-6 returns to his
office. He brings up the file on SCP-1548.
He is still unsure of this SCP’s true intentions.
It seems to be protecting humanity, but why? O5-6
sits back in his chair and scrolls to the end of
the file; there is an update to the file by O5-3,
something that wasn’t there before. O5-6 opens
the new entry and reads the caption: “all that's
left of our infinite, ever expanding universe.”
O5-6 scrolls down. The image is a picture taken
by Sepaph-1 before contact was lost forever. It
is a picture of all that remains of the universe.
There are two dots of light, and nothing else but
blackness. The swarm has destroyed everything in
the universe except for those two far away stars
and our own solar system which was protected by
SCP-1548. But how long can it hold out, against
a universe destroying force. Only time will tell.
Now go check out SCP-2935 O Death and SCP-2000 for
more tales of an apocalyptic
scale from the SCP Foundation.